hello welcome the 9th
lunch meeting online and live on bs it's
Friday I see October 9th
first I would like to give you an overview
of the president's agenda for
next week Monday and Tuesday
President Anne  line will be in glasgow
united kingdom to attend the
united nations pardon conference
on climate change
then on friday the president will receive a
delegation of members of the
united states congress here at berlaymont she will also
chair
a meeting of the group following this meeting  from
advisers on the copy of 19 via
video conference
let me also point out
that there will be no college meeting
next week and now i'm
passing the floor to sonia who has an
announcement about our cybersecurity efforts
on  this list there is
no symbol of its security electronic
devices all major titles
shows proof of its security à foix
l'estival 600 have by the way  s could mark
we want to improve network resilience
protecting beta as steward christine
hainry during the risk of monetary
rubs two majors all offer
consoles or summer air 600 ch is
mobile phone tablet and product 8 each
cube with chronicles and ingvar internet
osso toys and schalkwyk  whitman est
orange world
tricot
we
for more information
thank you very much sonia finally i
would like to remind you that during
public holidays
monday and tuesday our duty spokespersons
will of course be at your
disposal for your urgent request
you will find the names and time contact details
for the  weekend only for Monday and
Tuesday on our site the press room
on the other hand will therefore be closed we will
meet again here for the next
meeting at noon next Wednesday
since there is no
college meeting that's who  close word
announced we can move on to your
questions
nawab
[Music]
a
director political negotiator
[Music]
d'aude et chardy
l'instant
rignault cristal de toxins investigation on
a fixed distance of meetings
written debt is possible to open
combine in vienna
5 above his cabbage for peter
taken said they would take a
photo interaction  time and fit days on
visse
franck ambitious and second
-hand lawyer
[Music]
please
welcome back you
liters point in time
at the casino what
we provide an
animated peter mira mirabelle asking for
nature town hall because
if the author gilles simon
wright here our
woodson windows what you confuse
[Music]
no fortis a passive building machine
we have measured its management
[Music]
sistine flourishing arts
they have ten
connected
in
the
hair
cover
of this
is enough adequacy below
the
[Music]
technical
failures  from the experience thing
notice to
sam fans who
describes
the bambini
sarkozy
fine only one bar of the 37
22 moving commissions earn against
10.5 at the
bcm of the farewell  still stayed five
save at
all costs I'm waiting for
you to
find prison and who take risks
and end up down
philippe
here yes hello it's not exactly
on the world in question but it's on
a development of say arm  of iron
between the european commission and
poland the polish government
seem to have summoned the
belgian ambassador to protest after a
speech by the belgian prime minister
who said that the polish prime minister
played with fire by announcing
the third world war which would be
started  by the commission the
one before
you seem to be interrupted fact is
broken asia continues
so ask you if you had a a
reaction to this development of the sphere
not at all as you know we
never comment bilateral issues
between between  member states
and we have here expressed our
point of view on the appropriate language
in relations between member states
mathie  U I see that you had raised your
hand on this subject I think fine
it is on the Polish plan and
declarations yesterday of the president
fondard the hatred that we will consider that
the chapter in mende is closed if you
have additional questions  on
this subject please contact
balazs and we will continue on the
subject so related which is that of the
plan ask naked your question asia
yes hello so
so yesterday the president set three
conditions
for a positive evaluation of the
Polish recovery plan
I wanted to see if they were indeed
the only ones or does she have others
who are still discussed
with Warsaw
thank you mathieu so on the one hand
she had already mentioned these three points
during these remarks at the end  of the debate
in the European parliament last week
secondly we have always said here
very clearly on the podium and that is
why I am not even going to
ask eastwards to repeat it that
the evaluation of a plan  it's
something global
that corresponds to a whole series of
criteria and if the president
emphasized the three points you
mentioned, it's because the subject of
the independence of justice and the subject
of  which is obviously
the focus of attention because of the different
developments that we will have we
have been able to see in recent weeks and
in recent months of
course a sinequanone condition as
she said it is necessarily an
extremely important condition but
we close  our overall analysis of the
plan also taking into account the other
elements which are those for which
corresponds to the evaluation of
both all the plans
here is
mosey en d1 mathieu deflem
follow-up question
is what at the present time since the
time that  you are
discussing with the Polish authorities
is it only these
three that remain
to be implemented, the rest being already
completed will help him in a positive way
by  mathieu commission we
do not make any specific comment
on the state of evaluation of the plans as
you know we will communicate on the
result of our analysis once
this one is concluded
you are still with a show of hands
last should
not
ok
moselle vocation of
[Music]
1 2 times or like you go to remo thank
you raymond you had a question
yes I speak ok yes hello
it's just
to have announced to you that maros sefcovic he
will meet the swiss minister of
external affairs on the 15th  November so
I wanted to ask what are
your expectations and do you expect
a blur as they say blake in French
compared to
the many files this son who sees
there who are a little open thank you thank you
very much to remo listen to it  is a
meeting which takes place at the request of
the swiss minister of foreign affairs
mr cassis is therefore of course the
european commission which is always
always open to dialogue
expects
to  extend the message that mr. cassis will come to
convey during this during
this meeting I unfortunately can
not say more for the moment
a follow-up question
a breakthrough we say in French for a
brief here it is the word comes back to me no
more questions ok
thank you  i'm coming back so now i'm
also going to petter i don't know if your
question is about switzerland
but if not i'm coming back to mauzé in
the summer thanks for only
speaking if it's a son ok very well mauzé
we come back to you
win  speaking of a borders
in nice and to date
stéphane and sandrine troadec mayor christiane so we will see
you in made china moreover
hard to speed up she's in
2009 and judges that another program it
becomes terrorists and police
like  movement
rests everything
[Music]
fifth at and at
mtv report sine die but
you got therefore made
contacts
facebook
and twitter fought
peter
we lost peter
du nitrite grande
yaka
came from monaco is the
one whose my so  it seems
pieters au
indy mean time we will go to lorenzo
was sold out you might she lorenzo
united everything in crisis
would have bines at
basic information from sichuan
euronews in greece
[Music]
discriminated
[Music] it
all
starts
1,200 years both mechanics
language is
this is
it you keep crisis yes
you help us
[Music]
she
uses
your
lorenzo on a matter of faith
there will be half of the employees who
will be
what me  I switched to French
Isn't that
half of the employees will be sacked
Is this evaluation known
by the commission Does the
commission have
an estimate to
ask how many employees will stay
with the new the new service is
a  another question is what is
behind all this also a request for a
reduction in the budget from the
european parliament because I know
that there is still a
discussion inside there was a
discussion inside  eur of the paneuropean culture committee
and that there were
requests to reduce the budget
dedicated to these activities
twelve years later we
see the quality of the information or not
of this product serves sorry I wonder
and in French in the  information that
we have does not hold exactly
what was said there is indeed a reduction in
jobs but it will
not be half but I fall quickly
asked the chain is directly
what are the consequences
this  that you in the end this way there as
I already explained before a
decision of a private channel which must
then
explain these decisions vis-à-vis
occupy kits the ball face of magic
but and hop here is therefore it is not  in
my opinion it doesn't beat my opinion according to the
information I have it's
not half it's much less so
it's the majority of Greek service jobs
are maintained
the second question not in this
European reduction and banners were doing
no comments just yes finally I
don't really know but I can perhaps
remember that in the cockade
we concluded with euronews we foresee
a reduction in matches but
actions without the program which finances
most of the funds paid  euronews but
that's not all there are also
programs which are
acquired its ticket apart from certain
linguistic areas which are therefore well put
in empty hands with 6.6 at a
reduction provided just to
allow to see open calls and  a
certain flexibility with which one
can react
to changing habits but happy
us and of course annoy has also
appealed to have as a
consequence so it's not as
sketches are covered are also
open to euronews but that's just a
small  part like most funds
will stay but it will be it will decrease
for years to follow
thank you calls for proposals mr what
david told me your question is about  euronews
yes after i thank with i will have a
question on facebook but but
i will start with paris au loonie
also i
can actually
a toy i wanted to ask you what
are the five language versions who
who who the channel offered with
which you have  match
I don't understand how it works the
system if you can not explained
johannes because normally finally I
believe that there are calls for
tenders we say that these are our conditions
my radio channel responds to a
call for  offers with the Italian state to
transmit
the meetings of the parliament its pub etc there
are all the commissions which are put
by the Italian state
and in this case
apparently it is an agreement one makes
like that its direction that the commission
can say  what she wants like chen
linguistic
broadcast by paris re muse i
really don't understand how it works
the system is why you don't have
the power to say no we need y
because capa of greeks who  go online
frankly
I went through active online but that
's your comment but that's when
the procedure yeah
procedure precisely it's not calls
finally I'm trying to explain that but we
can also deepen
bilateral silver but that's not  'in coke and in
this framework agreement which was signed for
the next three years ago after
contracts which comes below in fact and
which defines or which are based in fact
for funds and in serious cases
framework ixic  re offered us 5 of the
house language areas offer six gifts
they offered they will now
hold English French in any case
Spanish German and Italian
they are not offered Greek so that
's the languages ​​there are others  languages
which are not supported by this
framework agreement which are not that they are
not part if you want of this agreement and that
they are added with other
agreements than venice with other
partners
so that's just that  walk
why i think  is explained is that
I can explain it so after it is up to
you of us whose this framework agreement to
make the choices it will detail but also
if you want
if you want therefore the commercial choice
according to
the authority after there is  a certain
we are going to say criteria well set and
not that in dependence the chain is
also that it is the basis of our
commitment with their us that
European orientations therefore
daily news looks and everything that passes
the cover with an angle
exclusively European and also for news
which is rather and national so these
are the criteria which are fixed on this
and which are if you want the
raison d'être for this
privileged relationship because it is a channel
with a position  European which has
no competition so out of 7 in this model
so here it is but I can't say
much more on that
thank you
I don't see any other questions on this
subject and so I'll give the floor to
petter david I'm fine  understood that you
had a  e question on facebook but
petter had already asked to speak
before so we'll come back we
'll come back after
doing some exercise going up and
down the stairs there
is
he
can't
suspect the
[Music]
they
were  all there
written proof this jump to 5 in
coaching a come back to you on the date
of issue
beaten
and
nestlé said stéphane d'astous fought
we
all
have terrorists
no ok this we come back to david whissell whatever
we are
say facebook
yahoo
facebook 5
i wanted to ask
you about facebook about few and
revelations of the last few weeks
[Music
] about the practices of this
company who who who who probably
is more than a company
you i know there are  negotiations
in progress on what you have already
proposed etc
but here we are going we are going well beyond
I believe the legislation which must
apply to all economic actors
with the revelations of facebook people
and the other malmö teas testimony i
see me if you have a
political reaction or if the commission
can do something with the
current legislation to
somehow respond to these practices that have
been revealed by cl document thank you
uranus
thank you david for being  very honest I did
n't quite understand the question
because you gave our little one the
answer in your question already so
it's not the particular question
so I think our position is
very clear for us the power of the
big platforms  vis-à-vis
public debate must be
must be
subject
to rules that are validated
democratic lemonade that's one of the reasons
why we put on the table
a transfer proposal according to the
services of moritz is what we call
is said and it is in English and who
is currently discussing it between the co-
legislators so I think there
we have a position which is extremely
strong and which is particular in Europe
and who we discuss we also explain
with our partners in the united states in
the context of dealing with technology years
so
i don't really know what do you want
what do you have in mind haven't
forgotten what i could
go back in more detail but I think
our position is very clear
maybe you'll give him
david's details
yes so it's it's facebook can
reveal the practices of a company
she
she can't control the
hate speech misinformation
it favors profit over
let's say the rules that prick themselves who
should be applied etc there are a lot
of teeth so it's difficult to hold on
I wanted to know if today with the
legislation in force
the commission can do  something
because we go well beyond
what other game platforms do
it's not google it's patrick rigout there
are competition problems or
sometimes
small or less big problems there
really c  is systemic especially
because the social dimension of facebook is
much more important
yes I understand I think that we already have
today with this system which
allows us to work with the
platforms of it is very good we have
an eye  co2 of practice than automatic driving
so with regard to
disinformation with regard to
hate hate speech which you are
referring to
but it is true that of course there like
the trade directive which governs more
by arming the platforms and it is
true that the reason why we have
precisely proposed a
much deeper and horizontal management 11
which is the draft regulation for
online services is of course of the
seven that there is it does not exist otherwise what
we would not have  not proposed is there
precisely we have if you want
since we proposed these
obligations which come more and more
with the importance of the
platform so there what we call the and
very large p  online platforms so
in facebook ferrer so given their
number of users
gone and so that means there are
approaches to
audits in terms of algorithms
there is therefore certain transparency
so for the algorithms so there are
certain things that are
which are offered as well on
the this ski the transparency of
the rules in fact which govern when
we continue to be easy we have
erased the Caennais Canadian plasma of
the possibility for the user
to appeal to decisions and
cough  coughed coughed proposed is all
equal today it is not there in
the same way it is quite obvious
thank you therefore the strengthening of the
regulatory framework and certainly
necessary in
order to give us more means
to deal
with this kind of this kind  problems that
can be made to appear
as the platforms
develop
thank you I don't see any other questions
on this subject are there any other questions  So
for us today
no so I wish you a
I wish you a good weekend and we
will see each other again on Wednesday thank you very much